guru just has to move his  face closer to the cam  there we go  i feel like i had this against neon 7  before  oh i wasn't supposed to say that  could be some other guy who knows  nobody knows nobody knows  potassius you're so quiet are you on  your tinder yeah i was just doing some  stuff sir but i'm back now  are you we need your support we're  having yeah yeah  it's like um minus is still five points  behind  and i'm playing pretty badly as well you  can do it you can do it we need the  three musketeers we do i'm gonna take  i'm gonna take you one trip to the um  yeah just shut up and go  do your tinder on toilet and then come  back and then we're back preferred  to win this thing  yes  there we go  all right still a second but one point  fine but 69 and that's the best  like if you finish in 69 that's the best  yeah yeah sure that's a nice score  whatever